NOW TO A BLOCKBUSTER AUDIO
RECORDING JUST UNVEILED AT THE
OATH KEEPERS TRIAL.
IT'S FROM AN ALLEGED PLANNING
MEETING AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION
AND A FEW WEEKS BEFORE THE
INSURRECTION.
THIS GROUP DISCUSSES FIGHTING
FOR THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
TALKED ABOUT WHAT WEAPONS TO
BRING TO WASHINGTON.
FIVE MEMBERS OF THE FAR RIGHT
MILITIA GROUP ARE ON TRIAL FOR
SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY.
THEY'VE ALL PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
CNN LAW ENFORCEMENT
CORRESPONDENT WHITNEY WILD IS
OUTSIDE THE U.S. DISTRICT COURT
IN WASHINGTON.
WHITNEY, WALK US THROUGH THESE
NEW RECORDINGS.
>> Reporter: WELL, ANA, THIS WAS
CAPTURED BY AN ATTENDEE.
IT WAS A ROUGHLY TWO-HOUR
MEETING THAT OCCURRED IN
NOVEMBER 2020.
THE DEFENSE -- EXCUSE ME, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, RATHER,
HAS BEEN TRYING TO DRAW THIS
TIMELINE THAT BEGINS SHORTLY
AFTER THE ELECTION AND LASTS
THROUGH AND EVEN AFTER JANUARY
6th.
IN THIS RECORDING WHICH AGAIN
WAS ABOUT TWO HOURS, THIS IS
MOSTLY STEWARD RHODES, WHO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SAYS WAS
LEADER OF THE OATH KEEPERS,
LAYING OUT PLANS FOR COMING TO
WASHINGTON.
THROUGHOUT THE RECORDING HE IS
SAYING THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
PRESSURE TRUMP TO INVOKE THE
INSURRECTION ACT AND REPEATEDLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
BROUGHT OUT EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT RHODES BELIEVED IF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT INVOKED THE
INSURRECTION ACT THAT THEY COULD
BASICALLY CARRY OUT THESE
PARAMILITARY PLANS THEY HAD BEEN
PUTTING TOGETHER FOR SEVERAL
WEEKS.
AGAIN, THROUGHOUT THIS RECORDING
HE SAYS THAT THE OATH KEEPERS
WOULD BE WAITING WHEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT INVOKED THE
INSURRECTION ACT.
HERE'S A QUOTE FROM THAT
RECORDING.
>> AFTER THAT MEETING, ANA, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BROUGHT
FORTH OTHER EVIDENCE IN WHICH
TWO OTHER ALLEGED
CO-CONSPIRATORS, KELLY MEGGS AND
JESSICA WATKINS, WERE SAYING
THAT PEPPER SPRAY IS LEGAL,
TASERS ARE LEGAL -- EXCUSE ME,
THIS IS DURING THE MEETING.
THEY WERE SAYING THAT PEPPER
SPRAY IS LEGAL, TASERS WERE
LEGAL, STUN GUNS ARE LEGAL AND
IT DOESN'T HURT TO HAVE A LEAD
PIPE WITH A FLAG ON IT.
IT WAS AFTER THAT MEETING THAT
THEY'RE ACCUSED OF SAYING THAT
THIS WAS THE MOMENT THEY WERE
WAITING FOR, THAT THIS WAS THE
CALL TO ACTION.
THE DEFENSE TRIED TO ZERO IN ON
SPECIFIC PARTS OF THIS.
IT WAS BASICALLY THE WORD
"LEGAL."
AND WHAT THE DEFENSE WAS TRYING
TO SAY WAS THAT IN FACT THIS
RECORDING SHOWS THAT PEOPLE LIKE
STEWART RHODES AND KELLY MEGGS
AND JESSICA WATKINS WERE TAKING
GREAT EFFORTS TO ACT WITHIN THE
LAW AND THAT WHILE THE LANGUAGE
MAY BE BOMBASTIC IT WAS NOT
ILLEGAL, ANA.
>> AND REMIND US, WHAT DO WE
KNOW, WHITNEY, ABOUT CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN THE OATH KEEPERS AND ANY
TRUMP ASSOCIATES?
>> Reporter: WELL, THE
DEFENSE -- EXCUSE ME, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, RATHER,
PRESENTED EVIDENCE USING ONE OF
THEIR KEY WITNESSES HERE, AN FBI
AGENT, WHO SAID THEY WERE ON
THIS GROUP CHAT CALLED FRIENDS
OF STONE.
AGAIN, THIS WAS A GROUP CHAT IN
WHICH THEY WERE DISCUSSING
PLANS, AND THE FBI AGENT SAYS
THAT ROGER STONE HIMSELF, A KEY
TRUMP ALLY, WAS ON THIS CHAT,
ALTHOUGH THE FBI AGENT DID NOT
EXPLAIN IN WA WHAT WAY STOEP MAY
HAVE ENGAGED WITH THEM, ANA.
>> WHITNEY WILD, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US THAT UPDATE FROM THE
CORRELATEHOUSE.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN NATIONAL
SECURITY AND LEGAL ANALYST
CARRIE CORDERO.
A KEY PIECE OF WHAT WE LEARNED
WHEN THEY UNVEILED THIS NEW
RECORDING IS THERE WAS A PERSON
WHO APPARENTLY WAS AT THIS
MEETING WHO TIPPED OFF THE FBI
THAT THEY HAD THIS RECORDING AND
THAT THIS WAS THE CONTENTS OF
THIS MEETING AND THIS WAS BEFORE
THE INSURRECTION.
AND YET THE FBI DIDN'T CONNECT
WITH THIS PERSON IN ADVANCE
BEFORE THE INSURRECTION.
IT WAS AFTER, IN MARCH WHEN THIS
PERSON WENT BACK TO THE FBI AND
SAID HEY, I HAVE THIS RECORDING,
HERE'S WHAT WAS SAID, DO YOU
WANT IT, DO YOU WANT TO TALK TO
ME, AND THEN THEY EVENTUALLY
DID.
SO WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO ALL
OF THIS?
DID THE FBI DROP THE BALL ON
THIS?
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, ANA.
SO THERE'S TWO PARTS TO THIS.
THERE'S THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S ROLE IN PROSECUTE
ING ACTIONS LIKE THIS.
AND WE DEALT WITH THIS IN THE
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM CONTEXT
A LOT IN THE LAST 20 YEARS, IN
TERMS OF THEIR ROLE IN
PROSECUTING AND BRINGING TO
JUSTICE PERPETRATORS OF CRIME.
BUT THEN THERE'S THIS PREVENTION
PIECE.
SZMYT INTERNATIONAL CONTEXT THE
FBI WORKED FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS
TO PREVENT ACTS OF INTERNATIONAL
TERRORISM.
AND SO WITH THIS LATEST PIECE OF
INFORMATION.
BUT IN ADDITION, ANA, LOTS OF
INFORMATION THAT HAS COME TO
LIGHT OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR THAT INDICATES THERE
WERE ALL SORTS OF OTHER
INDICATIONS THAT THERE WOULD BE
VIOLENCE ON JANUARY 6th RAISES
THE QUESTION OF WHY THERE WASN'T
BETTER WARNING IN ADVANCE TO
THOSE WHO WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THE PHYSICAL SECURITY
OF THE CAPITOL.
SO I DO THINK THAT THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL PIECE OF INFORMATION
THAT CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS
IN PARTICULAR ON THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE AND THE OTHER HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEES SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THE FBI AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATIONS WERE
DOING ENOUGH ON THE PREVENTION
SIDE.